battu pau verdier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wen qui m'a demandé joué pendant plus
deux seuls pris plaisir à ses parts pour
vous highlander monde là bas sinon
chatel sur les coûts il faut ce beau
ça fait un mal de chien bonsoir à tous
et 3 décembre escaliers très réussie
alors
nolwenn leroy vous êtes ici ce soir pour
nous parler de votre nouvel album qui
s'appelle volk voilà il imite narbon
soir
en trente ans de carrière j'ai reçu les
plus grands dirigeants de ce monde
michael gorbatchev boutros boutros ghali
shimon peres mais je n'ai jamais reçu de
miss univers c'est la première fois de
ma vie
alors certes
techniquement voulait que la plus belle
fille que je n'ai jamais reçu évidemment
mais comment être sûr qu'il n'y a pas
assez j'ai super
[Rires]
bon soir
[Applaudissements]
non
mais cela
alors mais tu ici ce soir pour nous
parler de votre nouvel album est tout de
suite il s'appelle du vent dans les
couilles on écoute un titre
[Musique]
en fait mauvaise blague pour évoquer ce
qui a été un scandale national pendant
une semaine au départ ce que roselyne
bachelot ait d'autres ont justement
appelé une agression sexuelle laurent
oui n'a crucial avait raison or en
addition elle avait raison une agression
sexuelle et on a des images bien sûr
magnétosphère j'ai fait partie de mes
chanteurs préférés mais non mais c'est
vous qui le dites je sais pas qui
c'est l'ambiance du trou du cul
[Applaudissements]
c'est une jeune maman et 70 une jeune
maman la belle et jeune maman qu'est ce
que tu penses de nolwenn leroy j'aime
pas du tout
alors qui j'aime pas la femme et je
trouve qu'elles sont de la bouche
franchement
on se connaît depuis longtemps c'est
pour ça que j'écris ce
que j'adore nolwenn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà assez dur comme ça pour lui
d'abord je voudrais m'excuser parce que
je fais quelque chose de pas bien j'ai
touché à la chute d'une fille c'est pas
bien je le sais je l'expliquais mes
enfants et je les fais quand même alors
du coup j'ai consulté et le psy m'a
conseillé ce petit bêtement mi saison
qui va m'empêcher de faire pas mal de
conneries
et puis
plus sérieusement je voudrais dire aussi
deux trucs d'abord je voulais m'excuser
auprès de nolwenn parce que la pauvre
les venues défendre un album formidable
on lui parle que de ça et c'est un peu
chiant pour elle et moi qui suis très
sensible à la cause des femmes battues
je sais que la prochaine fois que je
vais prendre la parole pour parler de ça
on va me jeu ont même jeté la séquence à
la gueule donc j'aurai beaucoup moins de
crédits on est tous d'accord pour dire
que c'est pas le meilleurs gags de ma
carrière non et si c'était à refaire je
ne le referais pas d'accord j'étais dans
la joie de revoir une copine et déconner
avec elle et est vraiment c'était ni
fait ni à faire mais ça ne méritait pas
cette vindicte et c'est tout sur ce
qu'il faut dire quand même c'est que
c'est ça je dis pas chaque fois que
c'est ça nous blanchi parce que on a été
blanchi sur tout mais là le csa nous
appelons et je remercie le ciel ça
[Applaudissements]
alors si ça coûte rien ce que je peux
non remonter un peu non
quatre centres plaisir
alors heureusement donc le csa avait été
saisi mais marc event in avaient été
choqués oui à part le jupe gates
[Musique]
alors pour en parler avec tous les deux
principaux protagonistes
laurent si tu pouvais éviter de
recommencer bien sûr ce soir surtout que
tu as une jupe mois gdra même temps quel
droit bien entendu nolwenn alors nolwenn
à l'époque personne n'avait voulu vous
écouter mais vous aviez déclaré à la
télé s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui n'est
pas misogyne c'est bien laurent baffie
d'ailleurs depuis il m'a envoyé un
bouquet de fleurs et un petit mot plein
d'humour il a dessiné une [ __ ] sur le
petit moi
même pas
d'où c'était délicat c'était c'était
magnifique c'était que je crois que
c'était tu sais ce que c'est c'est eh
marquées concernant notre enfant et oui
c'est ça c'était avant d'être il ya deux
affaires en une il ya aussi la faire de
notre enfant que je n'ai pas déclarés à
la mairie du boulou et tennisman qui
passait
donc tout ça est très
les garçons les yeux qui brillent
ouvrage venu voir sourit jeu
défi alors vous savez louis que nolwenn
un astéroïde à son nom ouais ouais dans
la ceinture principale
qui était découvert en 2010 par stéphane
curtil devons nouveau mexique et le nom
a été donné à cet astéroïde
nolwenn drogue parce qu'elle a fait des
actions caritatives c'est en hommage à
vos actions caritatives ne saviez pas
non mais toi tu es une comète attendons
est à petit que
garder son nom on a va passer ça
vraiment un astéroïde a beau nom mais
oui mais oui bien sûr c'est le seul
oosterwyk avec dieu bleu
c'est vrai c'est absolument faire qui
passera très loin des est ce que vous
savez nolwenn qu'un scientifique
américain cette fois qui lui est
spécialisé dans la musicothérapie a
révélé que votre voix vos chansons
pouvaient avoir un effet positif sur les
lésions cérébrales vous le savez ça mais
la tyrie quand il ya un type qui
savaient le 14 février j'ai fait du bien
d'un peu ce qu'est ce que c'était les
fréquences delà de la voix en fait et ça
enfin ça n'avait rien à voir avec la
langue dans lequel je chantais où les
chansons c'était vraiment les fréquences
dans la voix quand la musique et c'est
vrai que et des voix qui sont qui font
du bien et puis d'autres qui vous
revient le cerveau avait pas ça marche
pas terrible sur le rush mais on voit
aussi savant jeu grand boucle
février
pourtant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
goss htc
la loi nous fait du bien oui on voit
d'ailleurs ça marche vous avez vendu
trois millions de disques depuis le
début de votre carrière
en 2010 vous avez vendu 1,3 million
d'albums avec bretonne 400 milles avec
au fil de l'eau alors le problème après
j'aime c'est parce qu'ils s'étaient
assises avait vendu 88 mais aujourd'hui
à 6 étant évolué par rapport à la
musique et ventes d'albums aussi et on
achète malheureusement aussi plus autant
d'albums c'est le scandale
aujourd'hui quand même dans ce sens mis
l'album c'est quand même pas c'est pas
dégueulasse ce cas rien mais c'est vrai
que vous aviez été absente pendant cinq
ans et c'est vrai qu'il faut occuper
l'espace il faut occuper l'espace non
mais aujourd'hui il faut sortir plus
régulièrement des projets c'est vrai
qu'avant on pouvait se permettre
justement moi j'ai fait l'école bluesy
de partir quelques années retrouvé
l'inspiration écrire des chansons
tel un orfèvre un artisan prendre son
temps aujourd'hui c'est beau travailler
plus voilà ses rêves non mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la preuve c'est que vous
sortez folle un an seulement après je ne
sais pas si ça va bien plein d'artistes
dans le l'urbain dans partout
aujourd'hui les albums donc ça a vu ces
intrus johnny c'était un album par an
ouais bah non c'est un peu c'est moi
c'est moi j'écris mes chansons
effectivement c'est ça prend un certain
temps et bah oui c'est vrai que c'est
difficile en même temps d'écrire des
chansons et d'être dans l'action on est
de nouveau un album de reprises voilà
bah ça te laisse te tente justement de
décrire les gens sans vous reprenez donc
treize titres de chanteurs exclusivement
masculin mais c'est pas du tout le
concept de l'album le concept de l'album
c'était bien reprendre des chansons des
années 70 de ce mouvement et de cet état
d'esprit qui était alors évident c'est
plus facile de chanter les je t'aime des
autres que les biens moi j'ai souvent
tendance à écrire à utiliser beaucoup de
métaphores beaucoup de l'image publique
mais mes émotions et c'est vrai que là
c'est parfois plus simple d'utiliser oui
les mots des autres pour exposer
certaines émotions ça m'apporte beaucoup
or dans l'album s'appelle folk way pour
une album de folk en même temps est pas
con parce que par association d'idées tu
de repères
heureusement vous est donné un peu plus
de mal pour votre fils sinon mes
lauriers appelés fils
ou merlin quoi je vous mets en garde
merlin je me savais c'est déjà de ré
merlin est bon c'était un peu compliqué
est ce que le papa va bien papa fabien
un peu froid aux couilles mais je veux
tout
soixante balais je vais l'avoir bien ça
va avec arnaud est très bien c'est une
histoire qui dure 10 - oui avec en même
temps 11 ans à 11 ans
et toi ton et on s'en va dans les zones
de conflit en ce moment l'un d'eux
écoutez en ce moment entre passages
si j'écoute les gens je pense que je
suis comblé parce qu'apparemment normand
d'amour heures en ce moment oui c'est
vrai on répète la terre entière
exact nous dire la vérité dans quelques
instants et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu